since we all love data and we gathered
some numbers for this event so we had
two keynote speakers
six committee members
we had 11 sponsoring companies we had 21
talks
more than 320 attendees and we've raised
45
000 Euros which all these proceedings
are going to an organization called num
Focus
you're asking who Nam focuses
I will tell you
I know
so noun focus is a non-profit
organization which
um
yeah
yes supports open source projects and uh
and events such as this for knowledge
sharing
if you are interested for more details
you can always visit their websites and
see all the projects that are sponsoring
afterwards we want to thank our hosts
High Tech campus and AI Innovation
Center for allowing us another year to
host it to hold our event
thank you guys this is such a memorable
venue and we really loved it to be here
we want to show our deepest gratitude to
our sponsors without them we would not
been able to actually have Pi data
Eindhoven 2022
so we are really grateful for all their
donations
we want to give our special thanks to
our keynote speakers
their words of wisdom will last will be
staying with us for a long time
we want to think of for oh we want to
thank all our speakers for their
insights their expertise and they took
the time to come here and share it with
us
we're gonna give our special thanks to
our volunteers for showing up on time
and putting the hard work to run things
smoothly thank you guys really
appreciate the effort I hope I see you
next year as well
we want to give some small thanks to the
committee members and I'm really really
happy that I was part of them of this
group
this event is our baby and we are so
proud of it and I hope you all enjoyed
it we've worked out we worked so hard to
make it happen
and
I really looking I'm really looking
forward to do it over again
so
if you're interested to be an organizer
please either come to us you will see a
person with this t-shirt on
or contact us via email or social media
we are always happy to look to to get
new people to in our group
and if you're interested for more events
there is a pi data Meetup
coming up in January all I can tell you
is currently that is going to be held in
a castle
and if you're interested for more
details
[Applause]
if you're interested for more details
please scan the QR code it's going to
redirect you to our Meetup page and
we will update it with more information
for other events I was informed that
there's gonna be a pi data Berlin
Conference in between 17 and 19 of April
so if you're interested for attending
another Pi data please have
please make sure that you're checking it
out I think their website will be up
soon and otherwise maybe it's up the
website is up so you will have all the
information available
so without with that said
thank you guys for coming a pie data
wouldn't be Pi data without you actually
the audience matters the most when it
comes to this so we are really really
honored to be here
with you guys
[Applause]